becomes master  we'll be cousins just lower the shoulder  down  he's that's just a frustration right now  for the Marcus doesn't he has not had  one of his better games and  [Applause]  Terry Rozier not a happy camper you see  it and Bane's in him doing some banging  I think he'll flop yeah I think you'd  think Bane swapped and I think he stood  over them told me put clapping was  because Bane's gave him that little hit  with his chest on that first one so  cousins was going to return the great  favor and smartly vanes knew it was  coming yeah so he set him up right here  I'm gonna take two I'm gonna take the  hit but you're gonna get the file  yeah smallest guy in the floor Terry  Rozier wanted